[Musique]
Philippe Pascot bonjour bonjour nous
vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle thinkerview
d'être là on voudrait avoir votre prisme
de lecture votre expérience sur ce qui
se passe au niveau de la corruption de
la politique
des élus et de l'argent public ou dans
le détail en général vous avez écrit un
bouquin qui s'appelle Pierre d'État et
elle est tous vous faire trois points
sur 5 c'est pour ça
de suspension ce qui veut dire que tous
les élus sont pas pourri quand même et
j'en ai aussi écrit en 2014 qui
s'appelait délit d'élus
où je référençais plus de 400 élus
j'écris ça avec raser Jérémie qui avait
mis les doigts dans la confiture j'en ai
créé un autre aussi qui est pas mal
aussi que je conseille parce que je
connais l'auteur aussi qui s'appelle du
goudron et des plumes vous savez ces
gens qui trichent dans la vie et qu'on
met sur un sur un rail et qu'on met de
qu'on couvre de goudron et de plumes et
je pense que quelquefois il y a quelques
élus de la République qui devrait un
petit peu goûter au goudron les plumes
pourquoi il goûte pas à ce fameux
goudron ils sont protégés c'est un
réseau est-ce que c'est un réseau qui
sont protégés ils sont entre eux c'est
eux qui font les lois
bichette ils ont l'économique maintenant
derrière eux et puis le Français a pas
de couilles le français aujourd'hui je
me rends compte qu'il préfère avoir des
élus corrompus que des élus intègres
parce que un élu corrompu il vous fera
sauter vos PV un élu corrompu il vous
permettra à votre fille de rentrer à
l'université on passait un petit coup de
fil au recteur malgré le fait qu'elle
n'ait pas eu les bonnes notes un élu
corrompu il embauchera votre fils à la
cantine ou comme comme cantonnier donc
le problème il est là aussi c'est que
les gens votent pour des élus corrompus
tout en le sachant c'est de la
subordination de vote c'est pas de la
suppression de l'autre c'est de des
petits arrangements entre amis je veux
dire vaut mieux avoir un élu corrompu
qu'un début intègre parce qu'un début
intègre il vous fera pas sauter vos PV
si même si on est tous d'accord
sur le fait d'avoir des élus intègres
quand c'est chez soi si on en a un qui
est un peu magouilleur on aime bien
c'est aussi une des problématiques que
j'ai rencontrées on a un petit proverbe
sur cette chaîne qui est assez fou
l'aveugle ou assez politique qui leur
crève les yeux choisis ton camp ouais
ouais j'aimerais bien que les gens
choisissent quand le problème c'est que
les gens choisissent par le camp j'ai le
même problème par rapport à plein de
choses dans la société quoi où les gens
sont pour l'électricité à condition que
la centrale nucléaire soit pas à côté de
chez eux ou les gens sont pour le bio à
condition que ils puissent la voir où
les gens veulent être à la campagne avec
Carrefour à 5 minutes donc j'ai vraiment
un problème de d'éveil de conscience des
populations par rapport aux hommes
politiques mais j'ai des trucs de fou
j'ai le casier judiciaire vierge je me
bats depuis maintenant 4 ou 5 ans pour
que tous les élus un casier vierge la
loi page je lance une pétition 180
000 signataires au bout d'un an et demi
je lance un chat contre un mur
20 48 heures après j'ai 5 millions de
signatures le problème de la population
c'est qu'ils sont complètement dans
l'émotionnel donc si je lance un chat
contre un mur j'ai des escades de gens
qui se mobilisent pour trouver le
coupable savoir où il habite je lance
une pétition sur le casier judiciaire
vierge qui est le b.a.ba que tout le
monde reconnaît que tout le monde dit
que c'est normal aujourd'hui il y a 396
métiers je les ai compté un parrain où
il faut un casier vierge pour travailler
si vous travaillez dans un journaliste
si vous fait un casier vierge si vous
travaillez dans une mairie pas
journaliste si vous travaillez dans une
mairie vous êtes obligé d'avoir un
casier vierge pour être titulaire et
fonctionnaire si vous êtes condamné
pendant votre boulot dans la mairie vous
pouvez être licencié sans indemnités par
contre pour diriger la mairie vous
pouvez avoir détourner du pognon vous
pouvez avoir violé si vous n'êtes pas
inéligible vous pouvez toujours être élu
c'est un non-sens absolu et ben j'ai du
mal et ben je rame tout le monde est
d'accord mais personne ne bouge le
président Macron le président Macron
Emmanuel Macron
le deuxième menu il y avait pas dans les
tuyaux une loi de moralisation de la vie
politique c'est une loi bidon la
moralisation chez je le dis aujourd'hui
monsieur Ferrand je pèse mes mots à
menti à ces députés novices en disant
que la loi qui avait été fait le premier
février 2017 donc j'ai reçu un des
grands organisateur de la loi en disant
qu'elle était anticonstitutionnelle ce
type là a menti au députés de la loi
n'était pas anticonstituée et il y a une
autre dame qui l'a dit qui s'appelle
Nicole Ferroni on est devant un but et
on a un ballon et le mec qui commence à
dire bah non on va pas taper dans le
ballon parce qu'on risque le but ne
risque de ne pas rentrer pourquoi ils
ont pas été jusqu'au bout pourquoi ils
ont fait une pseudo loi de moralisation
une pseudo loi cette loi en plus est une
honte manifeste vous rendez compte
on a plus le droit d'embaucher sa femme
et ses enfants comme collaborateurs
c'est génial on peut quand même
embaucher sa maîtresse ou son amant mais
pas sa femme et ses enfants est-ce qu'on
peut faire un engagé sa femme ses
enfants par quelqu'un d'autre
mais il faut même mieux maintenant ils
ont trouvé la combine parce que les élus
quand il pose une loi comme ça parce
qu'on les yeux oblige il trouve toujours
des maintenant il faut mieux maintenant
il est fondé
par exemple le maire de Drancy sa femme
est une élue maintenant les gens parlait
ce matin je sais plus quel autre élu a
fait que sa femme est devenue députée
c'est génial ils ont même plus besoin
comme collaborateurs en fin de compte
ils ont fait des lois uniquement encore
une fois pour masquer la réalité parce
que ce qu'on voulait c'était pas
d'embaucher sa femme ou son fils c'est
que les gens travailler réellement et
sur l'emploi fictif des collaborateurs
ils n'ont pas du tout légiféré il
voulait que je vous en donne une autre
allez un truc génial
les conflits d'intérêt c'est génial les
avocats bah voilà ils gardent quand même
les avocats certains aujourd'hui un
député peut toujours être avec or il n'y
a pas mieux
quand on est avocat pour avoir des gens
qui comme par hasard vous payent des
honoraires mais pire avant la loi de
moralisation on pouvait connaître le nom
des clients
et ben dans la nouvelle loi on connaît
même plus le nom des clients maintenant
c'est secret c'est beau c'est génial
c'est pour notre intérêt que ça a été
fait c'est évident que c'est pour
l'intérêt du peuple c'est-à-dire nous
manipulent et le pire c'est qu'on s'en
rend de moins en moins con puisqu'en
plus l'information commence à être de
plus en plus vous verrouillé donc on
vous donne une information
stérilisée ouais politiquement
correctisé
toujours McDonald's et toujours le même
McDonald's que vous alliez en Russie et
j'ai beaucoup voyagé vous rentrez dans
n'importe quel McDo vous avez le même
McDo qui vous rebaisse qui vous donne du
cholestérol mais vous avez le même et
quelque part malheureusement ça rassure
les gens quelque part les gens ont moins
peur de l'inconnu c'est une soumission
consentie ouais c'est une soumission
inconsciente consentie et qui maintenant
devient éducationnel
parce que là aussi quels sont les
risques les risques de préparer des gens
qui subissent des gens qui sont sous le
joug qui
permettez-moi d'être trivial
des gens qui se font [__] à sec et
qui disent merci et qui en plus disent
merci parce qu'en plus les élus sont
très forts
ils changent de slip souvent mais ils se
lavent pas les fesses donc du coup on ne
voit que le slip propre mais on voit pas
qu'en dessous ils sont pas laver les
fesses les élus parce qu'ils sont pas
tous comme ça non je le dis toujours
c'est important tous les élus sont pas
pourris mais plus on remonte en haut de
la pyramide et ce n'est pas un symbole
maçonnique plus malheureusement on
rencontre des élus pour X vous savez
combien coûte une campagne
présidentielle 50 millions 50 millions
d'euros 50 millions d'euros et qu'on me
dise pas que c'est pas vrai il y a un
mec qui s'appelle Sarkozy qui s'est fait
gauler et quand vous voyez la campagne
de Hollande quand vous c'est à peu près
le même 50 millions ça peut se trouver
avec un peu de creux de fonderie
des gens nantis qui vous donnent de
l'argent en masse plus ou moins
légalement je dis bien plus ou moins
légalement mais je me dis si moi je te
donne trois ou quatre millions d'euros
pour ta campagne présidentielle
qu'est-ce que je vais vous rendre
derrière merci
vous comprenez très vite c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec les vaccins j'ai
comme l'impression par exemple que les
11 vaccins
il y a un petit remerciement quand même
à des gens qui ont donné du pognon parce
que il y a un truc vachement simple dans
le vaccin et moi je suis toujours un
type très terre à terre je suis pas
contre les vaccins personne et contre
mais qu'on m'explique pourquoi on fait
avec ça pour la rage un gosse de 3 mois
et un vaccin pour l'hépatite B
[Musique]
malheureusement les gens sont dans
l'apparence un élu intègrent c'est pas
le mec qui est sur les forcément sur
tous les plateaux de télé c'est
quelqu'un qui bosse c'est quelqu'un qui
fait vraiment son boulot c'est quelqu'un
qui râle qui fait des rapports celui-là
on vote pas pour lui ou pour elle
Isabelle Attard elle s'est fait dégager
au premier tour c'était une nickel
chrome et j'en ai plein des élus comme
ça qui était nickel c'est ceux qui se
sont fait dégager en premier pourquoi
parce que un escroc
c'est le mec contre qui en a confiance
un escroc il est sympa il connaît le nom
de ton fils il te serre la main tu le
vois la télé il est bon c'est
malheureusement pour lui que tu vas t'en
promis un type qui s'est beaucoup
communiqué ça ça me rappelle quelqu'un
mais comment il s'appelle
mm mais un produit marketing
un bon produit marketing celui qu'on
connaît pas un an avant et puis un an
après il est président de la République
comment il s'appelle j'ai oublié son nom
qu'on voit sur toutes les chaînes de
télé qu'on voit dans tous les journaux
Macron voilà voilà ça c'est un bon
produit marketing pas sûr que dans le
paquet Bonux il y a un joli cadeau
est-ce que on va on va prendre le cadre
on va prendre le camacron alors
est-ce que pour certains ça peut être le
JFK le JFK le Kennedy qui a été obligé
de gérer le système financier n'oubliez
pas que Kennedy le père de Kennedy était
un super truie Lander et c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a mis
pour arriver aux élections des gens le
savent pas il y a quand même eu des
truandage et des achats de voix etc même
si Kennedy je respecte mais je dis
toujours que plus grand et le rayon de
soleil plus grand et son ombre donc
comparé Macron et JFK on l'a déjà
comparé
on l'a déjà ça suffit demain ça va être
zeuses
ah bah ça il connaît bien les rouages il
sait même on dit que
vous ne faites pas confiance non mais je
peux pas lui faire confiance un mec qui
dans son programme à la page 27 a dit
tous les élus devront avoir un casier
judiciaire vierge c'est moi qui lui ai
fait la note pour qu'il mette ça dans sa
page 27 il demande ça à ses candidats ça
pas la salle à l'Assemblée c'est passé à
la trappe comment on peut faire
confiance à un type qui sur le Béaba de
la moralisation des élus commence à
truander comment on peut faire confiance
à un mec qu'il est la première chose qui
fait c'est de baisser les appels de 5
euros mais c'est quoi cette connerie de
faire de faire un plafond un plafond
vous rendez compte pour les indemnités
de licenciement au prud'hommes même en
cas de licenciement abusif parce que les
limites ok moi je suis pas contre on
n'est pas contre les vaccins mais 11
vaccins dont l'hépatite B pour les
gosses de 3 mois moi je suis pas contre
plafonné les licenciements mais pourquoi
en cas de licenciement abusif ça veut
dire quoi parce que les gens se rendent
pas compte ça veut dire que demain ta
gueule me revient pas dans le boulot tu
refuses de coucher avec moi
et ben je vais créditer 100.000 euros
puisque c'est jusqu'à 100000 euros et
puis l'année d'après je te vire pour
n'importe quoi si tu commences à
défendre un petit peu tes camarades dans
le travail et que ça me plaît pas ou
comme tu mets des choses sur blanc et
que moi j'exige qu'au boulot les mecs
ils disent des chaussures noires et ben
je te vire pour n'importe quel motif et
de toute manière comme j'ai un bon
avocat je te verrai je te paierai même
pas 100000 €. on va arriver à 20000
euros ça c'est une bonne loi vous
rigolez ou quoi je suis foutrage faudra
et ben ça c'est ce qu'on nous propose ça
c'est vous rendez compte il va supprimer
des cotisations sociales entre
guillemets et pas les charges les
cotisations sociales sur les salaires à
partir de 2018 mais est-ce que les gens
se rendent compte que c'est la mort de
la sécurité sociale et de la caisse de
la caisse maladie si la future
privatisation c'est ça mais c'est
évident les prémices de la privatisation
c'est le programme de ces gens-là entre
guillemets moi je peux pas Fillon Macron
j'ai dit de ces gens là ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que les gens en plus
vont gagner 50 euros par mois 3 en ne
payant pas leur charge sociale mais
après ils vont être obligés de payer 200
ou 300 euros pour avoir une petite
couverture maladie les gens se rendent
pas compte c'est de la folie c'est la
privatisation de la sécurité sociale et
des boîtes de maladie moi je suis faudra
que j'en sors pas compte et ça c'est ce
que nous propose monsieur Macron
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être dans l'air
du temps de d'une super l'air du temps
envers de quelques-uns c'est peut-être
dans l'air du temps d'une super
compétitivité
dire les chiffres nous disent contraire
les gens les riches sont de plus en plus
rappelez-vous il y a un rapport qui est
sorti il y a 8 personnes aujourd'hui qui
possèdent plus que 3,5 milliards
d'individus huit personnes il y a 10 ans
et ça les gens pas noté il y en avait
en 10 ans on est passé de 380 à 8 c'est
ça
l'air du temps l'optimisation oui le
petit musée pour quelques personnes
pourquoi on sait pas occupé dans dans la
loi de moralisation de de comment ça
s'appelle ce truc là ah [__] j'ai
oublié le nom excusez-moi
le verrou de Bercy
fait que que le ministre puisse
j'ai les profs tout ça c'est dans mes
livres c'est les ministres qui décident
si un fraudeur va
être poursuivialement ou pas et la
plupart du temps quand les mecs ont du
pognon je pèse mes mots quand les mecs
ont du pognon ils payent et donc ils
sont pas poursuivis ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que la justice c'est pas la
même pour tout le monde et quand je dis
que si tu es un petit fraudeur allez
j'étais un petit commerçant j'ai mis un
petit pognon en bas à droite je me fais
gauler etc à toi tu auras des poursuites
pénales par contre si je suis un gros
fraudeur que j'ai beaucoup d'argent je
paye une petite amende et je suis pas
poursuivi c'est normal ça et ben ça
c'est la loi Macron ça c'est la loi
Sapin 2 ok il a participé moi je deviens
fou de rage parce qu'on me dit que c'est
pour le peuple non non c'est au profit
de quelques-uns et j'en ai des preuves
je viens de vous le dire et donc pour
vous ça vient de quoi les gens sont pas
au courant de ça ou les gens ne veulent
pas être au courant et les gens boivent
les paroles bidon qu'on leur donne
conférence non ils savent pas et puis
ils s'en remettent aux gens qu'on le
savoir parce que les gens qu'on le
savoir ils sont là pour vous aider et
quand vous avez l'impression que les
gens qui ont le savoir vous disent
quelque chose vous prenez
malheureusement ça pour argent comptant
parce que les gens sont plus curieux
parce qu'ils sont pris par leur propre
problématique que quand vous avez
désespérant besoin d'argent entre
guillemets et que vous passez votre
temps à savoir comment vous allez
nourrir vos gosses vous avez plus le
temps vous occuper de la politique vous
avez pu le temps parce que vous vous
êtes au taquet vous faut que vous bossez
le samedi et le dimanche parce que t'as
pas assez de pognon pour nourrir ta
famille et que tu es obligé de prendre
un boulot en plus le samedi et dimanche
et c'est ça la société qu'on nous
prépare parce que c'est vrai j'avoue il
va y avoir moins de chômage en France
écouter bien ce que je vous dis parce
que prenez note il va y avoir moins de
chômage en France c'est sûr chacun aura
trois petits boulots mal payés pour
protéger comme en Allemagne comme en
Angleterre ou à des gens de 150 sont
obligés d'être pour d'être pompiste 150
mais il y a moins de chômage
officiellement mais les gens survivent
les gens vivent même plus ils survivent
et ça malheureusement c'est la société
vers laquelle on se dirige
et si on ajoute là-dessus un peu
d'intelligence artificielle qu'est-ce
qui se passe là c'est encore mieux c'est
de la folie qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez à l'intelligence artificielle
je connais pas grand chose encore une
fois tout progrès est intéressant si il
n'évacue pas le passé et la plupart des
progrès évacue complètement le passé je
vais vous prendre un exemple bien précis
moi je suis pas contre sur le bouton qui
descend la vie électrique dans la
voiture ça s'appelle le progrès sauf que
quand ça tombe en panne quand la vie
très baissée et ben on est mort parce
que ils ont complètement oublié la
poignée aujourd'hui la dématérialisation
c'est génial
les ordinateurs chez moi moi je bosse il
y a des matérialisations pour les bons
de commande tout doit se faire par
dématérialisation
tous les 15 jours l'ordinateur est en
panne et ben tout s'arrête parce qu'on
est plus capable de faire un bon de
commande par papier on n'est plus
capable de s'appuyer sur le passé pour
aller vers le progrès et quand le
progrès efface complètement le passé
c'est jamais bon parce que en plus il
faut que vous le sachiez dans tout ce
qui est numérisation intelligence
artificielle il y a que quelques
personnes qui auront des clés les outils
subissent les autres subissent comme
pour les élections les élections
personnes se rencontrent aujourd'hui il
y a des endroits où il y a eu 80%
d'abstention
80% d'abstention c'est le députés à
l'étranger il y a des élus je l'ai mis
dans mon dernier livre qui ont été lu
avec zéro virgule 5 électeurs sur 10
0,5 il y a des gens qui prêchent pour
l'abstention hors vote en se disant on
va arriver à changer les choses quand
déjà à 80% d'abstention ça change pas je
me pose réellement pas même quand les
gens sont lus avec 0,5% sur
0,5 électeurs sur 10 ça change pas
vous savez ce qu'ils vont faire
mais ils vont nous ils vont nous
proposer le vote électronique
pour lutter contre l'abstention
et le pied c'est que les gens vont être
d'accord parce qu'on va mettre tu te
rends compte c'est vachement mieux tu
pourras voter de chez toi en fait tu
n'auras pas besoin de voter le dimanche
les gens vont en plus gober ça mais le
jour où il y a un vote électronique il y
a pu aucune sécurité dans les votes
c'est ceux qui seront derrière l'écran
qui dirigent et j'ai les preuves
aujourd'hui je dis bien j'ai des preuves
aujourd'hui que il y a déjà des
truandage sur les votes électroniques y
compris sur des élections françaises
c'est grave ce que vous dites c'est pas
grave je l'ai mis dans mes livres j'ai
toutes les preuves de ce que j'annonce
pourquoi vous avez attaqué la suite de
ça mais pourquoi vous voulez combattants
c'est vrai
le principe de la défiation c'est quand
vous pouvez pas affirmer quand vous avez
pas les profs de ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui pourquoi je pose simplement
la question pourquoi l'élection
présidentielle le vote électronique a
été interdit
je veux qu'on m'explique
bizarrement pourquoi il y a des députés
d'une femme qui a reçu 600 codes secrets
pour voter sur les députés à l'étranger
pourquoi sur les primaires de droite et
de gauche
on sait aujourd'hui qu'il y a eu détruit
en âge et que Monsieur Juppé ou d'autres
ont même gueulé parce que soi-disant le
vote avait été inversé où je sais pas
quoi qu'on me dise pas que c'est
tellement facile aujourd'hui qu'on me
dise pas que c'est pas possible de
hacker
vous avez contacté un juge quelque chose
pour
le savent j'ai même il y a même des
endroits où sur des votes à l'étranger
il y a marqué votre double vote double
vote double c'est sur les résultats
l'électronique c'est un bonheur pour
tourner
et ça les gens vont être d'accord en
plus parce que mon problème il est là
c'est que on se rendent même pas compte
qu'ils font leur propre malheur en fait
vous êtes juste inadapté dans un système
de
personnes qui n'ont pas envie
dans ce que je dis dans ce que je dis je
suis un petit peu en avance je suis
désolé parce que j'ai une vision globale
et je pars du principe que je peux pas
faire confiance aux hommes politiques
c'est comme une banque quand une banque
vous fait un cadeau chercher l'arnaque
mais les gens comprennent pas quand une
banque te fait ah ouais je fonds
te fais un cadeau cherche l'arnaque
parce que les seuls personnes qui font
jamais faillite entre guillemets je dis
bien entre guillemets en cas de crise
c'est les banques ils ont même fait un
système là où ils ont voté parce que les
politiques rejoignent les banquiers
rejoignent les économies on va pouvoir
prendre ton pognon si la banque fait du
déficit donc aujourd'hui il y a un truc
vachement génial dont personne se
rencontre la banque fait des bénéfices
c'est pour elle la banque fait du
déficit c'est pour ses clients et les
gens et les gens
frappent dans les mains en disant c'est
le progrès quand on va vous supprimer
l'argent liquide
tout le monde applaudit mais vous rendez
compte la petite vieille pourra pas se
faire voler son argent si jamais ta
maison flambe et ben tout de suite ta
carte on te recrédit que l'argent mais
les gens se rendent pas compte que sans
argent liquide il y a plus de liberté
je vais vous leur donner du pognon à mon
petit-fils
je pourrai plus le faire la banque sera
au courant donc l'état donc le fisc je
veux payer un truc comme ça je pourrais
plus le faire
tout ça mon argent sera à la banque dès
que je l'ai touché en plus la banque
sera exactement ce que j'achète puisque
tout sera par carte donc c'est vachement
plus facile derrière pour me manipuler
il commence déjà c'est que je sors
exactement ce que tu aimes comment tu
l'aimes ce que tu achètes combien de
fois tu l'achètes donc je pourrais t'en
[__] une petite couche gentiment sous
forme de publicité ou de sollicitations
de ne remarketing voilà sans argent
liquide la liberté n'existe plus mais
les gens se rendent pas compte parce que
pour eux soit disant ça va être plus
pratique alors il mérite peut-être qu'il
ce qui est en train de leur arriver non
pardon mérite peut-être ce qui leur
arrive non tu le mérites pas parce que
quand tu te fais manipuler c'est trop
facile est-ce que est-ce que tu mérites
de te faire voler par un escroc non
parce que l'escroc et les gentil parce
que l'escroc est à baratiner parce que
tu as pas le temps puis tu l'as cru puis
le mec il est de bonne foi et puis t'as
juré que c'était vrai et toi tu as cru
que c'est comme genre etc les résultats
c'est un escroc donc est-ce que on doit
condamner les mecs qui se font escroquer
non
non on doit être beaucoup plus rigoureux
par rapport aux escrocs et c'est pas le
cas parce que en plus il faut le savoir
ces mecs là de moins en moins il risque
toi tu détournes 150 euros toi tu fais
tu bosses au black pour nourrir ta
famille et tu gagnes 150 euros tu gagnes
150 euros parce que tu refais les
carrelages ou tu refais la peinture chez
quelqu'un tu au bout de trois mois on te
fait vendre ta maison eux ils détournent
des millions d'euros 15 ans après ils
sont toujours pas condamnés
on a les preuves on a tout je vous en
donner un autre le mec de l'i eu même là
je suis blanc Savignac
qui a détourné des centaines de millions
d'euros il a été condamné à quoi
que dalle vous savez il distribuait pour
la paix sociale le mec qui bossait dans
je sais plus quel syndical Medef ou je
sais pas quoi là il distribue de
l'argent pour la paix sociale vous vous
souvenez pas de cette affaire là elle
est passée le problème c'est que ça ça
fait trois lignes après et ben ce mec-là
il est passé en procès l'autre fois il
arrête quasiment rien pris mais il a pas
parlé
vos objectifs certains journalistes vous
objectent de participer à la défiance ça
c'est le truc soit la défiance soit je
fais partie de la CIA soit je bosse pour
les Russes on m'a même fait le coup du
Mossad voilà ou du Front national je
suis un sous-marin du Front national non
non c'est l'inverse plus on sera
transparent moi ils pourront abuser plus
vous serez moins et pour en faire parce
que en fin de compte ces trucs là
perdure et ne se développe que sur quoi
sur l'opacité sur le fait qu'on sait pas
la misère intellectuelle oui ou la
misérateur mais la misère intellectuelle
organisée aussi vous voulez vous en
donne une petite allez académie de
Créteil ça vous dit quelque chose
concours de professeur des écoles là
2016-2017 vous connaissez la note
d'admission pour devenir professeur des
écoles 10
des écoles vous avez 3,5 sur 20 vous
êtes admis pour être professeur des
écoles l'année suivante puisqu'en plus
avant c'était bête pour te dire
professeur des écoles il fallait 3 ans
aller dans une école à étiolles faire un
peu de pédagogie faire un peu de choses
non non un an et demi après vous êtes
professeur des écoles pires avec la
nouvelle loi là c'est maintenant Pôle
emploi qui a appelé des gens bac + 2 Bac
+3 Bac +4 pour être instituteur dans les
écoles sans formation à trois jours de
formation
génial on prépare quoi là on prépare des
professeurs des écoles qui sont pas
formés ou d'autres 3,5 sur 20 qui savent
moins lire et écrire que les gamins
qu'ils doivent apprendre donc c'est pas
préparer vous êtes d'accord avec
Alexandre Laurent qui dit il nous
faudrait des bacs + 10 pour éduquer nos
enfants aux primaires alors il ne
faudrait surtout des gens formés parce
qu'ils sont de moins en moins informés
aujourd'hui il faut que vous le sachiez
moi je suis une banlieue sur une heure
de cours on passe environ 45 minutes de
discipline
les niveaux sont totalement disparaître
c'est-à-dire que quand vous avez dans la
même classe moi je vois en maternelle
mon épouse est institutrice quand vous
avez une classe où vous avez 7 ou 8
gosses de pays différents qui parlent
pas français vous faites quoi vous
faites comment et ben vous bâcler vous
comblez vous Bouchez mais vous faites
pas un véritable travail et ça on le
sait c'est une insulte pour l'avenir
claire c'est pas une insulte c'est un
constat c'est un constat que si on se
réveille pas de façon civique de façon
citoyenne pour dire NON arrêtez de nous
prendre pour des cons c'est nos impôts
rappelez-vous toujours que les élus et
nos employés donc sur la défiance vous
inquiétez pas on l'a rappelé il y a pas
très longtemps certains
ministères d'affaires étrangères que
c'était nos employés quand on vous dit
que vous participez à la défiance non je
participe pas la seule je participe à
l'éveil ça veut dire quoi de participer
à la fin c'est vrai il faut faire
l'autruche faut rien dire
faut faire comme certains élus
politiques je regarde d'ailleurs vous
approchez que certains élus reçoivent
des gifles ah oui mais j'aurais même dit
il y a pas longtemps dans une émission
qui avait des gifs il y a des gifs il y
a des baffes qui se perdent
j'assume j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait les
donner j'ai dit il y a des baffes qui se
perdent mais honnêtement quand vous
voyez ce qui se passe des fois tu as pas
envie de donner des baffes moi aussi
j'ai pas dit que je les donnerais mais
ça me débranche versus des menaces oui
quel type
de mort menace de voilà
de gens dont j'ai les noms ou bien
marqué dans un petit papier vous
inquiétez pas
mais oui j'ai eu c'est normal en plus je
suis pas achetable je suis pas vendable
surtout avec un casque
alors j'ai 8 ans je fais gaffe quand
même mais s'ils veulent me tuer
parce que honnêtement quand on commence
à toucher
total vous avez fait un chèque de 375
francs il y a trois ans est-ce que vous
avez la facture
c'est sur une autre affaire ça c'est
quand je me luttais contre les sectes
donc je balance une secte à la presse
etc deux jours après contrôle fiscal par
contre tous les gens de la secte ils ont
pas eu c'est bizarre
est-ce que est-ce que la
le peuple français n'est pas dans une
catatonie émotionnelle qui qui sera ou
qui est déjà l'anesthésié la preuve ils
ont voté Macron parce que c'est déjà
trop tard c'est jamais trop tard
c'est jamais trop tard on a vu des dans
l'histoire des choses des situations
désespérées qui en fin de compte basculé
complètement donc c'est jamais trop tard
moi je refuse le désespoir parce que si
je commence à dire sur trottoir je tombe
dans le fatalisme si je tombe dans le
fatalisme je vais dans le sens où ils
veulent on peut rien faire moi j'entends
souvent et je l'ai eu dans une émission
ou bah c'est normal les élus c'est des
pourris non c'est pas normal non non un
élu de doigt pas être pourri un élu
c'est fait pour servir pas pour ça
servir et les gens trouvent ça normal
parce que petit à petit on a tellement
ça rentre dans la normalité tu sais
c'est comme moi je me souviens quand
j'ai commencé ma carrière à 14 ans j'ai
bossé dans un endroit où il y avait une
morgue
et j'allais voir le mec le premier mort
cette secours puis 15 jours après on
prenait notre déjeuner au milieu des
macchamés le problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a tellement
tellement de corruption entre guillemets
que c'est en train de se banaliser et je
dis attention moi j'ai pas envie de
devenir un pays comme on envoie et qu'on
critique à l'étranger où on sait que
c'est un pays corroélu corrompu parce
que nous ça se voit pas qu'on est
corrompu ça se voit pas encore tout à
fait ça va se voir un peu comme le
Brésil quand la marée va se retirer ça
va se voir parce que c'est tellement
gros ce qu'ils font de plus en plus et
les mecs maintenant
c'est là où je dis qu'il y a une
sonnette d'alarme il faisait c'est il se
cache même plus avant il se cachait un
petit peu du temps de Pasqua c'était toi
les magouilles en dessous etc maintenant
c'est carrément je te balance des lois
pour regarde la loi qu'ils ont passé
juste avant Macron sur le Dili par ruse
avant quand un élu faisait un délit par
ruse tu avais 10 ans de prescription au
moment où tu constatais le délit je
rappelle écoutez bien c'est des
lipareuse donc par définition à des
disparus c'est caché d'accord donc quand
tu découvrais la magouille tu avais 10
ans de prescription et ben ils ont passé
une loi ou c'est 12 ans de prescription
alors les gens ont retenu 12 ans c'est
mieux ouais sauf que c'est à partir du
moment du délit
c'est à dire que si jamais un mec fait
un délit par ruse en 2000 et que tu
découvres l'affaire en 2011 tu as un an
avant la prescription pour boucler à
faire c'est génial si ça c'est pas une
loi pour les truands je veux qu'on
m'explique et ben cette loi ils l'ont
voté et ils l'ont voté tout parti
politique confondu
tout parti politique confondue et c'est
là où je dis qu'un malaise où est la
droite ou à la gauche ils sont en train
de se protéger mais les uns les autres
ils vivent entre eux
donc pas très longtemps est-ce qu'il se
protège de la fin dictée
le monde entier il y a des angles où les
mecs font voter des lois de la
municipaux c'est l'Italie non non pas
l'Italie d'autres pays en Amérique etc
les mecs se font voter des lois
d'amnistie pour eux
et ça passe
et ça passe c'est là où ça devient fou
toi je rappelle toujours tu truandes sur
50 euros on devant ta bagnole eux ils
trempent sur des millions d'euros ils
sont voté le mois d'amis si c'est génial
est-ce que les fous ont pris le contrôle
de l'asile non les fous n'ont pas pris
le contrôle ici parce que je pense que
ces gens-là sont pas fous parce qu'en
plus quand tu les fréquenté moi je les
fréquente ils ont bonne conscience ils
ont là ils ont l'impression de faire le
bien ils ont l'impression que eux savent
ce qui est bien pour toi aujourd'hui la
loi travail est-ce que c'est des gens
qui travaillent réellement qui l'ont
fait
c'est des énarques deux ou trois qui eux
ne savent pas ce que c'est que le
travail entre guillemets il travaille
ces gens-là ils ont l'impression de
bosser mais ils savent pas ce que c'est
que se lever à 4h du matin pour que
s'occuper des gosses d'avoir trois
heures de transport de gagner 2000 euros
par mois et de savoir ce que tu vas
mettre dans le frigo le 10 du mois parce
que eux encore de 1000 euros et encore
et encore et ben c'est ces gens-là qu'on
fait les lois pour nous expliquer
comment on allait travailler pour gagner
500 euros par mois il y a quand même une
distorsion à mon avis et de plus en plus
c'est ça c'est les nantis qui te disent
comment tu vas vivre en temps en étant
pauvre ok donc ils sont ils sont
complètement hors sol qu'on passait plus
corsol là ils sont quels sont je dirais
pas dans les nuages parce que on va les
comparer à Dieu quelles sont les
préconisations pour les faire descendre
de leurs nuage et ben arrêtez de voter
déjà pour détruire ça c'est le b.a votez
pour qui pour l'instant je veux dire la
meilleure des abstention aujourd'hui
c'est le bulletin blanc
voilà mais dans l'urne pourquoi parce
que quand il y aura 80% de bulletins
blancs dans l'urne ils seront obligés de
changer les choses obligé parce que là
ça se verra vraiment
en France et dans le monde entier
l'abstention Orvault ne sert à rien qu'à
renforcer la venue du vote électronique
claire net et son bavure l'abstention
dans le vote en blanc ou en une à un
moment donné ça fait basculer les choses
mais ça les gens se rendent pas compte
et ça les arrange les élus parce qu'en
plus et l'abstention ça compte pas et ça
comptera jamais donc les mecs
aujourd'hui je le répète je l'ai mis
dans mes livres sont élus avec 0,5
électeur sur 10 vous rendez compte ces
gens-là sont légalement élus mais sont
plus représentés moi j'ai des sénateurs
qui ont été lu avec 11 voix
lesquels
lisez mon légère monsieur vous le verrez
c'est dedans c'est dedans moi je suis
incapable d'inventer j'en ai un qui a
été lu avec on se voit l'autre qui a été
lu la carte les mecs ils font plus de
campagne d'élection il faut un dîner
il y en a même un qui a perdu deux voies
parce qu'il avait deux végétariens dans
ce qui les invités et il a faire pas
base de viande donc il a perdu de voix
mais vous rendez compte que c'est plus
des élections c'est de la magouille
c'est un cercle commun c'est de l'autre
fois c'est entre soi vous sortez un peu
avec vos bouquins dessus vous faites un
peu de pognon ah bah oui je me fais de
l'argent je me fais un euro par livre
vous en avez vu vendu combien 100000
140000 j'ai gagné 64000 euros et j'ai 70
000 euros d'un point à payer et j'ai eu
et j'ai eu un procès qui m'a coûté
50.000 euros faites le compte donc c'est
plus beaucoup par mois merci et j'ai
bossé 4 ans dessus comme un malade tout
seul
donc voilà j'ai gagné un petit peu
d'argent mais moi je l'ai volé à
personne et en plus donnez-moi un moyen
pour expliquer aux gens
je fais quoi sur internet ça marche pas
les journalistes ils en pensent quoi
tout ça alors il y a différentes
catégories de journées s'il y a ceux qui
veulent bien m'inviter il y a ce qu'on
peut et il y a ceux qui disent que je
suis un facho ouais ah mais il y a ce
qu'on peut j'en ai un qui m'a appelé qui
m'a dit mais Philippe c'est génial ce
que tu as écrit c'est la première fois
qu'on écrit un bouquin que tout le monde
comprend avec les preuves etc mais tu
comprends si c'est à l'époque où elle
s'était Premier ministre si Vasse
devient Premier Ministre Président je
suis grillé j'ai pas eu d'article
aujourd'hui
je suis jamais je suis toujours pas
passé chez Ruquier aujourd'hui je suis
toujours pas passé chez Ardisson
aujourd'hui j'ai fait aucune grande
émission politique
parce que Bourdin a reçu 150 messages
d'internautes sur Internet qui vit bah
quand ça s'est vous inquiétez pas parce
que lui il est l'intelligence de
m'inviter il a bien fait parce que j'en
suis à 15 millions de vues sur le petit
passage que j'ai fait chez lui mais moi
j'ai réussi à vendre j'étais déprogrammé
deux fois chez Ruquier
par qui poser des questions à la
personne qui est venue dîner chez
Catherine Barma un soir pour lui
expliquer qu'il fallait peut-être pas
faire vite parce que à son émission
en plus je suis passé dans l'Express
j'en suis à 140 000 ventes je suis dans
les 5 meilleurs ventes des livres
politiques en essais politique en 2016
ça intéresse pas mais pourquoi parce que
moi je tape pas sur la droite je tape
pas sur la gauche je tape sur le système
donc on peut pas me casser quand je vais
dans une émission on sait pas ce que je
vais dire ce que les journalistes qui
sont un peu conscients des fondamentaux
de soutenabilité économique ou sociale
ou sociétal appeler ça comme vous voulez
ils ont peut-être un peu peur que vous
allumiez la mèche j'ai allumé la mèche
déjà vous allez allumer pas grand chose
il y a 180
000 signatures sur votre Playstation la
loi était quand même votée 1er février
2017 j'ai quand même mais ça peut être
fait chou blanc mais au moins j'ai
avancé les trucs sur les rois qui ont
peur mais ils ont peur que je dis est
factuel je n'ai rien inventé quand j'ai
sorti là ils sont ils sont désespérés
que le que les que les parlementaires
entre guillemets parlementaires entre
guillemets qui avait ce qu'on appelle un
se déclarer comme agriculteur il y en a
une cinquantaine ne paye pas la
cotisation sociale de la MSA
en tant que parlementaire et même quand
ils le sont plus [__] il est chiant
parce que d'avoir sorti ça quand j'ai
sorti que les élus payaient pas leur
train à vie
que les ministres et Premier ministre
pouvaient voyaient sur Air France avec
leurs enfants gratuitement à vie c'est
moi qui l'ai sorti ils sont en train de
changer l'autre zozo là comment il
s'appelle de rubis là Monsieur durby le
nouveau président il a bien sorti un
petit truc il y a pas longtemps parce
que c'est la [__] mal après quand vous
le savez comme quoi les élus qu'on fait
plus de trois mandats n'auront plus de
billets de train et encore plein
d'autres trucs donc plus on sait plus on
est transparent et c'est parce que j'en
ai vendu 140 000 livres et que ça c'est
qui sont obligés de changer les choses
c'est parce que j'ai commencé à gueuler
en 2013 sur le casier judiciaire vierge
que tout le monde a repris les 396
métiers je vais vous donner un scoop il
y en a plus de 396
où on exige un casier judiciaire vierge
mais à 396 j'en avais marre de les
compter donc il y en a encore plus et ça
a été repris par toute la presse depuis
donc ça veut bien dire que on arrive à
faire des choses
faut juste insister et se servir des
médias et se servir des angles
médiatiques
pour venir aux journalistes oui
donc ceux qui ont peur à parler ceux qui
fonctionnent avec le système c'est
lesquels
il y a un type là
il vient d'être nommé je crois
j'ai fait deux émissions avec lui
très honnêtement c'était pas ma copine
avec un peu
les mecs qui dégoulinent d'arrivisme là
il vient d'être de mes potes parles tant
mieux pour lui
bon on va passer à d'autres sujets donc
on a fait le tour du vôtre on peut vous
creuser sur d'autres sujets ah mais
allez-y le terrorisme qu'est-ce qu'on en
pense je pense que le terrorisme on
prend pas les choses à la base encore
une fois
je me dère vraiment mes paroles sur le
terrorisme parce que je veux pas non
plus mais
la façon dont on laisse en dé j'arrive
jamais le dire ce mot déshérence des
populations des quartiers c'est le foyer
du terrorisme le manque d'éducation le
foyer du terrorisme c'est pas notre
politique étrangère mais aussi aussi
c'est aussi notre politique étrangère
moi j'ai pas mal voyagé j'étais au Tchad
en au moment de la faire tomber le bail
en 1973 74 il sait navré j'ai eu assisté
au coup d'État la France à l'époque vous
souvenez tu es un peu trop jeune mais
les camions comme ça où il y avait
marqué une publicité qui comme dans la
publicité interdite qui se suivait dans
les rues pour faire de la pub et je suis
pas t'as pas connu donc à une époque il
y avait des camions qui passaient dans
les rues avec de la pub dessus et ben
moi je l'ai vu au Tchad venez en France
venez travailler en France avec les
palmiers et tout donc on a fait venir
plein de gens parce que économiquement
c'était intéressant bon c'est pas donné
les moyens de les intégrer on les a
parqués sous-payés parce que c'était
pratique mais même encore aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on dit on lutte contre un
cercle de pas parce que dans l'arrière
salle de plein de restaurants dans les
quartiers huppés c'est vachement bien
d'avoir des Philippins sans papier que
tu payes pas cher et on peut garder le
même le passeport dans certains cas en
plus dans les dans le BTP
c'était vachement génial d'avoir des
gens que tu payais pas cher pour
construire etc ils esclaves mais
exactement mais officiellement vous êtes
bien les gens étaient parqués etc on
paye c'est moi j'ai l'autre fois j'étais
il y a pas longtemps sur Évry j'étais
dîner chez une dame marocaine de mes
amis ça fait 35 ans qu'elle en France 35
ans parle toujours pas français
elle parle toujours par manque que
marocain j'ai quand même un problème
d'intégration donc comme on sait pas
donner les moyens et qu'on a fait
socialement économiquement politiquement
exprès de pas se donner les moyens toi
tu arrives dans un pays
tu t'intègres pas et on t'intègres pas
qu'est-ce que tu fais tu restes dans ta
communauté tu restes avec les gens qui
te comprennent il suffit qu'il y ait des
mecs mal intentionnés qui viennent pour
tape t'expliquer et moi je les vois
faire dans mes meilleurs principes ou
pas c'est exactement pareil
c'est un domaine que je connais aussi
c'est parce que l'asecte au départ c'est
vachement sympa
c'est des amis c'est la famille il te
parle il te paye à bouffer tu as une
facté dedans une fois que tu as mordu tu
es mort tu peux plus en sortir tu peux
aujourd'hui il y a certains quartiers de
banlieue où tu ne peux plus sortir en
jupe quel quartier de banlieue
[Musique]
dans le 91 et dans le 93 il y a des
endroits tu peux plus sortir en jupe je
suis désolé
moi je l'ai vu
tu peux plus tu peux plus sortir parce
que tu te fais insulter moi j'ai ma brut
j'en parlais encore hier avec elle
hier elle est pas loin elle est au
Kremlin-Bicêtre
il déménage et que quand je dis ça je
fais pas de racisme primaire qu'on soit
bien d'accord parce que je me méfie
quand même je suis pas Front national
mais elle me dit je vais à la salle de
gym en short elle peut plus parce que
sans arrêt elle se prend des réflexions
dans la gueule les mecs classiques la
traite de [__] et pense que parce
qu'elle est en short c'est donc une nana
qu'on peut sauter qui a vraiment un
problème d'éducation et de laxisme on
ouvre une autre piste les flux
migratoire les flux de migrants
de migrants économiques et les flux de
migrants de réfugiés tous se mélange
si moi je crève la fin dans mon pays
qu'est-ce que je fais et nous on l'a
fait en France à une époque on est bien
parti conquérir d'autres fois parce que
en France il y avait la misère ces
gens-là font pareil faut pas se faire
des ions il y en aura de plus en plus
puisque en plus le pouvoir est concentré
maintenant comme je vous l'explique tout
à l'heure entre les mains de moins en
moins de gens sur de moins de moins
d'endroits ça veut dire que donc de plus
en plus en droit il y a de plus en plus
de gens qui crèvent la fin
ils vont venir on aura beau mettre des
barrières ils vont venir on aura beau
mettre des miradors ils vont venir on
aura beau mettre des mitrailleuses ils
vont venir le concept le mieux on va le
construire où ça en Italie
parce qu'ils ont aucune capacité à se
dire qu'il faudrait peut-être mieux
faire que ces pays-là se développent
c'est parce que dit Macron
là vous êtes en train de me fâcher là
parce que les promesses je veux bien
j'aime bien mais ces gens-là ne font que
des promesses la plupart des des
Alliances françaises etc ont déjà été
détruits par le gouvernement précédent
mais ils sont contraintes d'accentuer
les choses donc il y a de moins en moins
de moyens qu'on attribue pour le
développement des pays par contre il y a
de plus en plus de moyens pour exploiter
les pays émergents pour prendre le
pognon et là encore une fois qu'on me
dise pas j'y étais j'ai fait le Tchad
j'ai fait l'Ukraine j'ai fait le Mali
j'ai fait deux trois le Congo où j'ai
été pendant 5 ans non j'ai pas fait le
Rwanda j'ai fait le Congo moi la RDC
Kinshasa non plus j'ai pas fait de
Djibouti j'ai déjà fait j'en étais déjà
fait pas donc je peux vous dire que on
passe pas notre temps à essayer de
d'aider ces gens-là on passe notre temps
à savoir comment on va continuer à les
exploiter
ça peut pas marcher ces gens-là un jour
l'autre ils vont venir dire nous aussi
on a faim nous on si on veut des belles
gosses et en plus c'est des non sens
aujourd'hui on empêche les pays
émergents émergents de se développer
pourquoi parce que si vous vous
développez vous allez polluer
mais attendez eux aussi veulent la télé
eux aussi veulent le progrès pourquoi
ils auraient pas droit nous on l'a eu et
eux on leur interdit sous prétexte que
eux vont polluer il y a quand même un
malaise mais comme on refuse d'appliquer
des techniques de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler d'énergie renouvelable parce
qu'on veut pas tout ça parce que ça
rapporte pas d'argent
un truc vachement sage souvent dans mes
conférences le soleil et l'énergie
solaire il y a longtemps qu'on aurait pu
développer les panneaux photovoldaïques
sont les maisons en plus avec le
réchauffement climatique ça serait
rentable il y a un type qui s'appelle
Montebourg au moment où ça commençait à
décoller vous rappeler il y a quelques
années il a taxé ça 12%, ça fait écroulé
le marché ils ont réduit le nombre
d'années où on pouvait revendre de
l'électricité ils ont réduit le tarif de
revente de l'énergie solaire pourquoi
pourquoi
faites-vous la réflexion c'est déjà fait
si jamais tout le monde a son énergie
solaire on devient autonome non on est
obligé de payer pour le nucléaire on
devient autonome
on devient quand même autonome
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe donc on paye
pour le nucléaire la voiture électrique
on aurait pu s'endort sans acheter
puisqu'on en électricité en trou chez
nous tu vois ça les intéresse pas parce
que ce qui est intéressant pour ces gens
là
c'est des marchés captifs oui ou
peut-être que alors je me permets de
faire la vocalité du diable vas-y vas-y
j'aime ça le nucléaire ça va nous coûter
un bras à déconstruire on va se
retrouver avec une énergie nucléaire qui
va coûter un bras complètement on va
dire sous compétitif par rapport aux
nouvelles technologies
mais je sais pas je m'en fous qui va
payer je m'en fous qui va se faire
trancher la jeu je m'en fous qui va se
mettre pas les questions comme ça
c'est un discours qu'on m'a souvent dit
ouais tu te rends compte si jamais je
fabrique plus des armes on va perdre des
emplois on va perdre des emplois moi
j'ai pas envie de fabriquer des armes
point barre il faut avoir le courage de
perdre pour mieux gagner après c'est ça
qui manque en France
on te sort à chaque fois mais j'en cause
le plus bel exemple que j'ai c'est les
bouges
les bouges monsieur Vals salut Manu si
tu m'écoutes il n'aime pas quand je fais
ça les bouts rouges
tous les rapports disent que c'est de la
merde tous les rapports disent que c'est
dangereux de le mettre là-dedans mais tu
comprends ça a sauvé 60 ans
donc on te sort les 60 ans
Bob Cohen qui a fait un reportage sur
les armes chimiques balancées dans la
mer en face les bouges à côté c'est oui
mais je suis d'accord avec toi j'essaie
de prendre des exemples pour que les
gens comprennent une industrie mais oui
mais oui ça sauve une industrie
l'écologie ça sauve ça sauve des
dividendes moi je parle pas d'industrie
est-ce que le problème c'est le courage
ou le prisme de lecture à court moyen ou
long terme c'est les deux
le manque de courage et les gens n'ont
pas le prisme parce qu'ils sont dans
l'instant T ou dans les mentionnels
comme je te disais moi ce que les
solutions que je propose des fois c'est
des solutions qui qui sont pour dans 10
ans les gens veulent du tout de suite
est-ce qu'on t'a appris à consommer tout
de suite il faut que tu ailles ta télé
tout de suite il faut que tu ailles ton
téléphone tout de suite il faut que tu
aies ta voiture tout de suite donc il
faut que tu consommes tout de suite on
est plus dans une société de partage on
est dans une société de profit et de
consommation et la consommation c'est
immédiatement je veux mes tomates
immédiatement non arrête on va pas
attendre trois mois pour que les tomates
poussent des mers de toi avec des gènes
des maires de toi avec des OGM pour que
les tomates je les ai en 15 jours même
s'ils ont plus de goût même s'ils ont
plus de nutritif dedans même si mais mes
tomates sont là et puis surtout surtout
il faut qu'il se conserve trois mois
donc je mets des gènes de scorpion
dedans comme ça je suis sûr que mes
tomates vont être rouge pendant trois
mois visuellement
émotionnellement j'ai des tomates
gustativement
santé etc j'ai de la merde mais ça je
m'en fous ont des petites questions de
la communauté
comment fait-on pour avoir des
politiques honnêtes déjà le Béaba c'est
casier judiciaire vierge faut-il changer
le système politique le vote versus
tirage au sort oui je suis alors je
connais bien Étienne Chouard c'est un
copain
s'il y a pas longtemps j'adore ce mec on
a essayé de le chauffer mais il y a un
chauffeur j'ai essayé moi aussi mais
chauffable mais il a pas tort alors je
trouve qu'il a tort dans dans la suite
la totalité en tirage au sort je suis
pas sûr que ce soit forcément une bonne
chose parce que les gens n'ont pas
forcément envie
tu délègues à un moment donné un autre
donc et puis c'est honnêtement faire de
la politique moi j'en ai fait quand tu
l'as fait bien et c'est un
investissement et les gens ont pas
forcément envie de s'investir tous les
jours dans savoir comment je vais faire
pour faire la voirie comment je vais
faire pour faire le machin et ça donc
c'est moi maintenant plus de démocratie
par des tirages au sort c'est à discuter
par contre ce qui est sûr
je pars toujours ce petit plat cassons
déjà le système parce que le casser
cassons
pas chercher à le dépasser je suis
d'accord mais je fais vachement gaffe à
ce que je dis quand je parle ça
la plupart du temps on commence à savoir
les connaître tes solutions de
remplacement et comme on discute
tellement des solutions de remplacement
qui t'amènent des débats des machins des
pour les comptes enfin quand on change
jamais le système parce que tu vois si
tu commences
que faisons la verger le même problème
sur le casier judiciaire je vais
t'expliquer pour que les gens
comprennent les gens oui mais tu
comprends le casier judiciaire j'osais
mauvais il aurait pas pu être élu si
j'ai fait une petite connerie à 18 ans
je peux pas être élu et que ça
c'est pas mon problème
casier judiciaire c'est le b.a.ba
pourrait être élu on pose la loi et on
verra après les détails donc cassons ce
système de merde d'élection et comme
l'être humain n'aime pas le vide comme
l'être humain est suffisamment inventif
avec des gens constructifs avec un
casier judiciaire vierge etc on va
trouver d'autres systèmes de vote mais
le b.a.ba déjà en politique c'est le
casier judiciaire vierge il est anormal
qu'un mec qui a des tournées du pognon
gère mon pognon il est anormal qu'un mec
qui a violé une nana puisse encore faire
des mariages ou diriger des colonies de
vacances et aujourd'hui la politique
c'est ça ces gens-là sont facilement je
pense que pour les colonies de vacances
de vérifier un minimum quand même non
pardon mais non celui qui est animateur
dans l'inconnu de vacances mais un maire
qui a été accusé de harcèlement sexuel
lui il peut toujours c'est lui le patron
de la colonie de vacances et ça il y a
aucun problème une question de la
communauté vous avez travaillé combien
de temps dans la politique et 25 ans
pourquoi travailler dans
j'ai jamais travaillé dans la politique
j'ai toujours eu un métier à côté
pourquoi avoir mis autant de temps pour
dénoncer tout ça alors je vais le
reformuler différemment pourquoi j'ai
crache dans la soupe aujourd'hui
si les gens connaissent mon parcours
j'ai mis mon parcours dans un de mes
livres j'ai toujours été grande gueule
j'ai toujours ouvert ma gueule j'ai même
quand j'étais conseiller municipal avec
valse il y a des fois où j'ai pas voté
quand valse m'expliquait oui mais tu
comprends tu es pas assez intelligent
mais je suis passé intelligent pour
voter ça je le vote pas ça a été formulé
comme ça oui oui plusieurs fois sur des
décisions par exemple la fusion de
l'hôpital d'Evry à l'hôpital de Corbeil
les usines d'incinération contre
lesquelles je me suis battu Val c'était
plus ou moins pour il me disait mais tu
votes tu fais non non je vote pas tu
m'expliques pas je vote pas j'ai
toujours été un emmerdeur donc c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui vous a élevé
moi vos grands-parents non non je suis
parti à 14 ans de chez moi donc voilà et
puis je trouve que je dois avoir des
bons antécédents dans les gènes mais
masque non ouais catalan
auvergnat et breton
si j'avais pas été à l'intérieur je
pourrais pas dire tout ce que je dis
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a des choses
qu'on ne comprend que quand on a la
terre maintenant je n'ai jamais eu le
doigt sous la couture c'est pas parce
qu'on est élu qu'on est pourri moi j'ai
jamais accepté un pot de vin et on m'en
a proposé de quel montant et dans quel
million d'euros quand j'étais président
de la commission formation
professionnelle et apprentissage donc je
gérais 800 millions d'euros par an vous
avez dénoncé le principe non j'ai dit
aux gens au Cap je veux bien mais tu me
mets ça dans le contrat je les ai jamais
revu
on peut la faire sauter ouais bon on va
la mettre quand même quels sont les élus
calcome
il y en a une dizaine que je connais ils
sont plus durs ils ont tous été virés
ils ont tous été viré
le problème est français ou européen au
niveau de la Commission et de et
sociétales
plus légèrement monte dans
l'intelligence et dans le progrès social
et économique plus il se referme sur
eux-mêmes
moi on est pauvre
moins on partage alors vous parlez
beaucoup de corrompus mais qui sont les
corrupteurs
alors les correcteurs c'est aussi le
personnel et c'est l'économie
c'est les grands trusts aujourd'hui
c'est les grands pouvoirs c'est le
pouvoir aujourd'hui c'est l'économique
c'est c'est les mecs qui possèdent les
médias c'est les mecs qui possèdent les
grandes entreprises c'est ce qu'ils
veulent te vendre de la merde en te
faisant croire que c'est génial c'est ce
qui demande des produits facilement
alors que ces produits là sont en train
de t'empoisonner c'est ceux qui mettent
du E171 de dans tous les matins pour
blanchir les produits alors que les
produits sont noirs c'est une image ça
qu'on te vend du produit chimique pour
que la façade soit blanc dès que tu
retires le blanc c'est noir c'est ces
gens là et comme ces gens-là ont besoin
parce que ça se voit à un moment donné
de loi et d'élus pour se couvrir et ben
donc qui de plus en plus il compte les
élus il y a un système vachement plus
grave aujourd'hui dont personne ne se
rend compte c'est qu'il y a un
glissement du politique dans les médias
chroniqueuse là il va falloir qu'on
s'appelle non mais c'est de la folie
il y en a une quinzaine qui viennent
d'être embaucher
Sud Radio j'ai appris la vente dire que
Fennec elle était embauchée
c'est un ancien député il y en a moins
une quinzaine là qui vient d'être en
beauté empocher dans les médias pour te
parler est apporté la bonne parole c'est
ça qui me rend fou les mecs soi-disant
vont être indépendants de France
insoumise on peut vous objecter qu'ils
ont été dedans et qu'ils vont peut-être
pouvoir parler ah ouais mais j'attends
leur carte bah oui c'est ça aussi le
problème moi j'ai plus de cartes donc
depuis longtemps il garde tous leurs
cartes j'ai Raffarin il garde sa carte
il va être chroniqueur à faire non mais
j'hallucine j'hallucine
rushing
Bachelot elle oui mais à une honnêteté
de dire je ne suis plus en politique
ces gens là ils vont aller un pied en
politique et un pied et un pied dans les
médias mais je deviens fou mais là c'est
officiel tout le monde peut le voir de
quoi s'ils le disent bah oui tu penses
on revient ce que je te disais
précédemment remets la bobine à l'envers
la manipulation de masse à partir du
moment où il passe à la télé apparement
c'est le pouvoir les gens vont les
croire parce que c'est dans le poste
parce que ils ont la parole parce que
c'est eux qui parlent pour toi donc je
les crois je ne vérifie pas
et la plupart des gens tombent là-dedans
aujourd'hui j'ai des lancé un truc il y
a plein de temps les banques te
demandent par exemple
aujourd'hui quand tu fais retirer du
liquide de dire pourquoi faire à partir
de quelle somme 2000 ou 3000 euros
pourquoi faire moi je réponds à chaque
fois de trafic de drogue
même si parce que je paramètres de loi
qui me dit je dois ce que je dois faire
de mon argent
il y a aucun texte de loi il y a une
circulaire interbanque
mais les gens comme c'est le banquier
même là il triche je n'en ai des preuves
encore une fois moi je dis rien sans
preuve je dis simplement montrez-moi le
texte de loi qui me disent que je dois
faire de mon argent
et ben comme les banques c'est le
banquier c'est derrière le guichet et
ben les mecs ils répondent quand tu fais
un prêt le banquier te dit bon alors il
faudrait que vous mettiez votre vos
revenus dans ma banque
on dit ça te parle quand je dis ça et
ben non il y a aucun texte de loi aucun
pour négocier plus facile il y a aucun
texte de loi tu n'es pas obligé de le
faire alors après il te tiennent alors
je vous accorde pas le prêt mais je
porte plainte et je gagne
sauf que les gens le font pas comme
c'est la banque on arrive on arrive
presque à la fin de là notre émission
comme ça où les gens CD sur le terrain
du pouvoir c'est le pouvoir qu'il a dit
Ferrandi la loi 1er février 2017 sur le
casier judiciaire est
anticonstitutionnel c'est couillons de
députés novices le croit sans vérifier
pour ça qu'on les a mis là oui c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on les a mis là c'est
clair on arrive à la fin
c'est combien la soupe
c'est 15000 euros net par mois
je pèse mes mots un député c'est 15000
euros net par mois parce que les gens
conscription
à la façade au dessus de l'isberg mais
quand on tu payes pas ton internet
gratos quand tu payes pas ton téléphone
quand tu payes pas un tas de choses moi
je l'additionne s'appelle des revenus
annexes ça fait 15000 euros net par mois
parce que les élus en fin de compte ils
gagnent pas énormément faut pas croire
c'est sur les à côté
quand tu payes pas ta bouffe quand tu
payes pas ton téléphone quand tu payes
pas ton coiffeur quand tu payes pas ton
repas
ça en fait des tunes parce que toi le
travailleur tu payes tout
c'est peut-être pour ça que les gens
sont servis ah bah oui et puis c'est
peut-être pour ça que la soupe est
antenne mon bonne que j'ai connu plein
de mecs étaient vachement bien avant d'y
être puis dès qu'ils ont été élus c'est
bizarre échange ils se sont révélés bah
ouais c'est que tu goûtes pas la soupe
tu vois en fin de compte elle est pas si
mauvais que ça tiens j'en prendrai bien
encore un peu lesquels
plein d'élus Xavier Duguin j'ai connu ce
mec là il était génial quand il était
jeune
la préconisation pour le citoyen lambda
pour améliorer les choses voter blanc ou
nul voter blanc votez massivement blanc
ou nul le premier mec qui truande ou la
première femme ne votez plus pour lui
le voter c'est un acte citoyen si vous
n'allez pas voter vous leur laissez le
champ libre et entre les élections on
fait quoi ah bah entre les élections
faut parler moi je fais des conférences
toutes les semaines faut aller porter la
parole on est un aujourd'hui on est deux
demain on est 50 après-demain petit à
petit ça rend petit à petit on éveil les
consciences petit à petit il y a plein
de médias comme vous qui sont encore
relativement libre
je dis bien qui sont encore relativement
libres parce que j'en ai vu qu'il petit
à petit se faisait avec elle des médias
télé je suis pas là pour me faire des
tribunes et puis me taper des procès en
diffamation derrière il y en a lisez mes
livres tout est dedans
je peux pas te dire mieux je suis aussi
là pour que les gens s'instruisent entre
guillemets
un pour nous là
[Musique]
qui les achète en plus c'est bien
on a une dernière question qu'on peut
toujours nous inviter c'est laisser une
bouteille à la mer un conseil pour les
jeunes générations un truc qui sera
immortel sur l'Internet alors le vote
blanc tu l'as déjà dit
un truc au niveau quoi social économique
ce qui se passe par la tête alors
essayez imagine toi tu as ton petit-fils
de toi j'en ai pas encore j'ai 6 enfants
mais j'ai pas de petit-fils
essayer en vieillissant de garder votre
âme et vos sentiments d'enfants
un enfant ça partage un enfant c'est pas
raciste un enfant c'est c'est
bienveillant et au fur et à mesure tu
grandis on oublie tout ça essayez de
garder votre âme et votre vie d'enfant
tout en étant un adulte parce qu'il y a
rien de mieux que le partage il y a rien
de mieux que que de juger les gens non
pas sur leur couleur de peau mais sur
leurs compétences et ça les gamins
il faut sans calcul
nous dès qu'on commence à grandir on
commence à calculer on commence à peser
on commence à savoir un enfant quand il
a envie de te faire un baiser de faire
un baiser
comme un animal qui t'aime
ça me fait penser à stupéfip tu connais
stupe vite l'enfant tu l'as tué
des enfants dans le fonctionnement
pourquoi ça sert à quoi de te taper
dessus parce qu'on a pas la même couleur
de peau honnêtement en plus moi je
prends toujours une formule quand quand
tu es sur Mars et que tu regardes la
terre
tu regardes pas la couleur
on a qu'une seule race derrière et en
plus on a qu'une seule terre
donc si on la massacre on n'aura pas de
quoi il y aura que quelques personnes
qui pourraient on a on a su on pourra
peut-être aborder une prochaine fois
notre sujet sur la prospective
et au pape de l'époque une seule race la
terre une seule terre pour tous
Kadhafi ouais j'ai envoyé j'ai envoyé je
l'avais renvoyé j'avais fait ça sur des
t-shirts ils m'ont jamais répondu
pas grave Philippe Pasco merci c'est moi
qui vous remercie excellente après-midi
à vous aussi puis bonne continuation
surtout lâchez pas les mettre ne lâchons
rien n'oublions pas nous sommes le
nombre ils sont nos employés
[Musique]